وقد استعرض مالك شركه ايفاجناري فيريغوجين
تفاصيل عمليه باخموت العسكريه في مقال
مطول نشره على حسابه في تيليجرام ومن ابرز
ما ورد فيه ان هدف معركه باخموت لم يكن
السيطره على المدينه وانما دفع زيلنسكي
لارسال كثير من قواته اليها مما يتيح
للجيش الروسي تنظيم دفاعاته بعدما تراجح
في خرسون وخركف وقلب ريغوجين انه تم تحديد
مده سته اشهر لاتمام عمليه بخموت وجعلها
مفرمه لحم للجيش الاوكراني وفق تعبيره
واوضح ان الاهميه الاستراتيجيه للمدينه هي
في تقدم القوات الروسيه بعد بخموت للسيطره
على
حسب مالك شركه فقد وصلت خسائر الجيش
الاوكراني الى 50 الف قتيل منذ بدء
المعارك في بخموت وجاء قرار الانسحاب بعد
400 يوم من القتال دون استراحه ولعدم توفر
الذخيره وفقدان قوات فاجنر قدراتها
القتاليه التي تحتاج الى تعويض